memory I am know your pelvis something
else about an expert on this other topic
at all so I realize all of you in this
room you are too these are very good
questions to ask afterwards the hormones
Kennedy that we're going to hear from
each of our speakers you will each be
about 20 minutes if a question occurs
injuries among patients please cinedigm
have a chance to ask questions at the
end if I don't like that Faraday also
please turn off your cell phones if they
are on
oh yeah head of the Righteous among the
Nations support Mandela yeah me too to
2007's you explain the department that
honors non-jews who rested during the
Holocaust poor guy has an itch in halle
Vasquez's on Temple University in
Philadelphia and then bring the theme of
the righteous and inspired books in
English include shelters the Jews
stickleback heroes of the Mohawk and the
Righteous among the Nations match
against earn college into little College
in New York and have been patient
through diversity in New Jersey what a
guy as a child escaped remote into
France and confess
across borders very strong facilities as
well and on the register publications
and generation
and why
come on reflecting on the immensity of
the Holocaust or sometimes wonders how
vs. nevertheless managed supply
testified accountant with thousands of
survivors everywhere the answer light
and to help received by survivors on
non-jewish and Jewish rescuers who wave
twisted himself to help you on the run
in some 500 recipes are concerned many
of these help indefinite identified it
on it under the under sham sponsor the
program of righteous among the nations
this program was launched in 1962 when
the others and created the commission
for the designation of the righteous the
initial and most fundamental
prerequisite for this title is the
element of whisk the righteous cycle is
awarded to rescuers who knowingly animal
conscience we prepared even to risk
their life and medical community in the
event of health one or several Jews to
survive several more criteria we added a
nobody can be summarized as follows a
non-jewish person who will personally
and directly involved in health to at
least one huge
irrespective of whether the rescue
operation succeeded or failed at a time
when the Jewish faith was totally
helpless and in order to survive had to
rely on the aid of others and in that
undertaking the rescuer placed his or
her life and safety in jeopardy and did
not precondition such aids by any reward
or compensation monetary tangible other
but but acted mostly out of humanitarian
considerations and had not before during
and after the rescue operation cost
physical harm to choose and more other
nationalities and they're being evidence
of this principally by the rescued body
or other incontestable documentary proof
such a rest work is deemed to be worthy
to pay the title of righteous among the
nations the monumental criterion for the
righteous cycle is risk to the wife of
the West let's make no mistake the
dangers for would-be West with the
terrible wheel and not dominated
in Poland for instance large-size
posters plastered on bulletin boards in
a major city vulnerable populations of
the death penalty for anyone helping
Jews in any way whatsoever this one's
reputation super rewarding in the press
or over the radio in other German
occupied countries in France just one
example zhenya tocmai paid with his life
in the Maidana concentration town for
any Jewish youth in his school that you
managing the shinbone Sauvignon Blanc
wife for the Catholic cleric father
shocked to see on bnet who died in the
German camp after his arrest for
harboring several Jewish children in his
religious school in a ball near for
temporal wesker is in France had to pay
not only from the German over but also
from the old collaborating agencies Paul
Molitor German mission regime the French
release was notorious for brutalizing
person suspected of aiding Judith on the
role of such as Pauline both flash was
arrested and tortured by the police
after being implicated in
to choose she had been working for the
jewish inspired the george got a network
that assisted used on the moment and
she's on the list of the righteous there
were four principal types of 84 which
the efficient sponsored washes title may
be awarded two wrestlers of June's heat
up sheltering de stimulating moving
health of children let's mention each of
them shelter this means helping offend
you disappeared from public view all
intents and purposes by sheltering the
fugitive person in a place where no one
his right mind which suspected are
living soul was invited there it also
means to feed and care for the strange
person even exponent for the removal of
bodily waste the other form assimilating
this means trying to pass as someone
else Evan aren't you for this one needed
legitimate credentials a false identity
caught a false birth certificate the
proper address and place of work and
persons who would speak up for the
similarity to mutates a question moving
another form of help with the search
engines to flee from an endangered play
to another location either within the
occupied regions or across frontiers two
countries out of each of the Germans
another voice of the war such as Ritalin
Sweden Spain and Turkey
the finance for instance conditions were
risking the truth and efficient region
but let's open in the occupied zone of
the country such as indicate of a world
cup up to the mayor of bustle in the
lamp the doctor mom who helped choose
free from the occupied zone to the
so-called free told the bishop on to the
other period of the occupation which use
felt safer there and each week on the
list some diplomats also facilitate the
flight of any two thousand the German
hands the world is well acquainted with
the heroic activity of the switch
diplomat all Wallenberg who acted in
Hungary to save thousands of Jews also
worth mentioning in this regard are our
ceases to the vendors the Portuguese
Consul General in Bordeaux France where
we should thousands of Portuguese
transit sees the Jewish refugees in the
city on the eve of his surrender to the
Germans also young hot and dark wood
sample Sugihara the Dutch and Japanese
councils in kaunas continent lithuania
who likewise issued transit visas to
thousands of Jews stranded in that
country finally
the fourth the final category pertains
to the rescue of children persons
involved in that endeavor included those
who travel long distances to make the
proper arrangements is calling the
children's at any moment and made the
routine inspection visits to make sure
that shows will be wall well care not
all the local host families themselves
with the frightened children into their
home and shower there with affection
love and patience in France in
particular thousands of Jewish children
survive are being hosted and non-jews
hold all your religious and secular
children institution today's some 23,000
200 persons from all European countries
have been avoided device restarted
including slightly over 3000 from France
this so ever should in all fairness be
considered only a representative sample
of the real number of wrestlers who
largely remain unaccounted for if we add
up the number of Jews say in all
countries on the chair
domination we think they arrive at a
figure of well over 200,000 hence the
likelihood of an equal number of Westar
width of people who aid into one way or
another in France alone well it's the
three quarters of the initial 325
college children survives in other words
well above well over 20,000 so that the
closest 3200 French name will gather
ashamed righteousness is therefore will
be held any realistic number of French
persons we have been engaged in the
rescue of such a large number of Jews
and who may subsequently qualify for the
competitive righteous parking the reason
then for the relatively small figure of
rescuers Lindegaard a sham may be
attributed to several factors one not
all authors of rescue operations are
were the righteous title since they do
not meet the earlier enumerated criteria
for the cycle such as first-hand
testimony by the principal beneficiaries
of the West with ate too many of the
records and rescued died in the post-war
period hence their pencil rescue
narratives remains unknown only through
secondhand in here say accounts that
made by yourselves not be sufficient for
the attribution of the righteous parking
finally and this may be
perhaps the most important factor many
survivors finally appreciated painful
and psychologically indenting from
living the traumatic events associated
the whole time therefore prefer to
postpone to a later date details of
their earlier harrowing experience when
they underwent was the human Ivo deal
imaginable and some may even decide to
take the whole sordid tale together with
their own rescue which saved them but
not the immediate loved ones to take it
with them to their grade thus investor
view the 20 3226 west with cochlear
that's why his righteous not at the
precise statistics of non-jews records
for each individual country but as a
representative figure of the nature and
scope of Health to Jews by knowledgeable
Holocaust and which a much larger number
of persons participated and who had not
been accountable closely allied to the
devotees of righteous Gentiles are
though the many huge rescue through
their efforts and
organisations exerted superhuman effort
and great we doubled risk to themselves
to make it possible for non-jewish
restaurateurs to partake in this
humanitarian and Devon non-jewish rest
group who is subsequently cited as
righteous by out Michelle while they're
Jewish counterparts where and still are
largely overlooked I remember sitting
behind my desk that you have ashamed
part of the righteous and within stories
of rescue involved in non Jewish
presence while the rest population was
initiated by Jewish risk of it but I
couldn't deal with that it was football
the story of these Jewish density
efficient the story of these huge
rescuers ways to be told and their deeds
properly acknowledged for one kind of
country speak of rescue undertaken to
the Holocaust without mentioning of all
the Jewish festival at least the
principal ones when acting above and
beyond to say the movies of their bread
the question that is why this
significant facet of rescue operation
had not been in proper exposure anyway
have been overlooked by the major
Holocaust institutions the standard
response for dismissing the wall of Jews
rest earth and then a Jew helping you
tell the jew was merely doing what he
was obligated to
there's nothing to brag about it where
were the Gentile Pikachu that was a
behavior not expected of him and this is
there more merits special recognition
however this rejoinder to a disturbing a
challenging question his voice to
consciously or subconsciously avoid a
deeper psychological reason the answer
this perplexing question that much to do
with ideology and miss creation we
linked with the rebirth of huge
independence annotation homelands yard
efficient and Israeli state state
institution is not merely to face
Holocaust institution to be created but
also serves as a guide and intellectual
lighthouse but other later established
holocaust memorial at the same time
young asians position with regard to
Jewish rescuers and also to be viewed
within the larger context of designers
as
before and during the formative period
of Israel that minimized diluted they
went so far as to dismiss the
significance of diaspora of juvie and
Judaism so the eighteenth centuries span
of exile and never-ending persecutions
the message was that account to the
centuries of persecution Diaspar Julie
adopted a passive and submissive course
so as to whether the stones and survived
an important any requests and
countermeasures does not to further
provoke the forces arrayed penstemon
this is best borne out following this
argument is a record of Jewish behavior
of the Holocaust which was a display of
confusion helplessness and
submissiveness and eating the faint of
the Jewish people on the hands of others
the solar exception to this hapless
situation with a righteous Gentiles who
risk their life to save one several more
Jews and a constant consequently married
the appreciation and thanks of the juicy
one additional exception to this state
of near total paralysis suppose this
argument where'd a few examples of
Jewish vitality and bigger display of
the Warsaw Ghetto Uprising and by the
Jewish positive then the full bloom of
Jewish self-assertion came
tuition with the creation of the State
of Israel and the heroic record of
confrontation against more numerous and
powerful enemies bent on its destruction
that lasted for many decades after the
right of Israel the story of Jewish
rescue in the Diaspora persons and
organizations were displayed not
submissiveness and resignation to a bit
of Fame this incidentally was mostly the
response of major Jewish leaders
societies and other one but initiative
invented encouraged in a superhuman
effort to outwit the enemy and succeeded
in saving literally thousands of Jews
the record of these undertakings flies
in the face of the near mythical
depreciation of the f-word jewelry when
speaking of friends I have mine persons
of the caliber of George Carlin who saw
Bobby use that bus by Thomas Nelson
Havana gncel on today salable the dead
somewhere then easy yes Nikola by subtle
and the disco
as well as the organization we were
faced with himself to save other Jews
from duplication and equated it with the
saving of thousands of Jews director of
these people seemed to threaten the
ideologically establishments for total
Jewish helplessness in the Diaspora when
confronted with physical danger to
themselves then Amon forget the yunkish
on pinterest national helicopter award
was established by special parliamentary
legislation in 1963 during the Macan
being period of his real sister it is
therefore also a reflection of the
ideological mindset of prevailed from
the difficult period of visuals rise and
series of wars with neighbouring Arab
states legislators at that time felt no
need to mention let alone highlight the
unusual olive juice recipes and
attempting to stem the time of the Nazi
slaughter in which they solicited the
help of non-jews many of whom were
hailed and celebrated by the state of
his notes for yard for shame and hey i'm
at dimension when the discussion was in
israel in the 1950s on the creation of
god Michelle well first of all
the debate work on the date went would
be the day to commemorate the Holocaust
in Israel and the game of fires then
insisted that it should be on the date
when the Warsaw Ghetto Uprising for God
which is on the day of passion or evil
pathribal which is the fourteenth and
fifteenth of the song and the would
oppose that because pictures of the day
or is a celebration of the deliverance
and and month of the Sun God Allah is
one should not celebrate it is a month
of joy and happiness and so finally
after much given back it was decided to
inject yo mashallah between pizza pizza
is google on after Penza is over a week
after that your masha'Allah the 27th of
the Sun which is a descent into hell
catastrophe and then your week after
that comes Israeli day of Independence
typical map so you have this
distinguished and fits in with the
mentality another thing that is not know
when you're sharing the discussion of
the array the creation of god machine
multiplied seem happy also wish to
include determine google bar and he wish
to include in the upper chef intimate in
the Museum of Jewish am also the name of
the over 1 million Jewish soldiers that
fought in the various armies and the
Soviet Army American army refractometer
british army to show that she was fought
back but because of the legalistic think
the real problem involved in this and
appropriated soldiers from other
countries this was dropped the title of
the day of yahushua which was proposed
was young oshawa ameritech adult the
Holocaust and the rebellions in the
ghettos where we know it was very only
one metal nothin many Gators and finally
if a note title of young Shem the young
Michelle shouldn't go on the show up
without Guevara in other words hard cast
largest heroes heroes remember two
thousand heels and meet people took
dance fought back
so rescue was not on the agenda but time
is not turning a psychological momentum
of realignment that has brought many
nizzle to have a second look and got
some great individual and organizational
they asked which used it to save their
weapon is changing public opinion is
only beginning to penetrate the walls of
gotta share that has until recently
transferee somewhat aggressively fought
to stem this right and tight and
restrain the attempt to change its
long-established work agenda
organizations let us not forget do not
like to be told by outsiders how to
manage their business when challenged
the response is awesome resentment
coupled with efforts to be legitimized
those perceived as trying to meddle in
their affairs whatever the merits of the
ideas proposed this is part of
organization mentality on ladies day I
find that davish and slowly and
laborious Lee changing his policy in
this regard and is exploring new avenues
to grant an honorable place the Jewish
residues of Jews we can only encourage
it to proceed of that force with
youngish am taking the lead other
Holocaust institutions will follow his
example and assign Jewish mess with a
proper and dignified place
and yeah in terms of prize-winning
vacations a book called use them all
mwah which we hope
individual again therapy please come
forward sarah has also contributed a
number of articles to scholarly journals
and chapters to edited books includes
you
english one is positive labour camps in
paris and the second is whisking
genocides and sara is going to speak to
us from Jerusalem to Paris and finding
the batches of brass
so i am just explained the writers of
our installations recognized by yet
Michelle around on your smooth part of
those who actually help you during the
war the celebration will be slow and
incomplete and i will say
crunchbase actually around 3200 french
rogers ave officially recorded
the ages we work on still only less than
400 which was very different from other
countries such as for innovations
recommendation is the French gates
indeed again on the contrary to other
countries the request is to get michelle
has only been increasing since the
French state representative I've been
interested in the commemoration of the
rupture and began participating in
commemoration originally only
dealt with by the Israeli state indeed
if in Israel the title prices for
installations up in the morning since
1963 fry button did not show any
interest in collaboration which is we
went to 990 since then however a growing
number of she returns and even extra
elements a big pickup on the challenges
read the citizens who are Jews during
the second world war in this process I
shwasted as French appropriation of
Israel title may have been the most
fulfilled
the French Germans have indeed been
forging a new national commemorative
expression is used to disclose and on
january 18 277 president jacques chirac
Falconeri order two strikes at first in
an official ceremony and the function so
this is the piece you are talking about
violence haha awesome ultimate a chance
to choose to see it so maybe we can
discuss your Ponte i'm not totally agree
with the point was to to show um to mix
right of people from the war and the lot
of them were women so the most of the
black and white issues are some of the
routers and i know most people from
today's firms without any we got come
back
so instantaneous which are short I will
from the way the French is French Mexico
appropriation has been taking place and
try to address the sheets in meaning of
the commemoration which works with the
appropriation and pay attention to the
role played by form of Jewishness yours
in the process
so first um I will address briefly
because again just talk a little bit
values to see original Israeli title of
lysosomal connections I'm trying to only
supported this collaboration was and
being diplomatic and foreign relations
revelation so my personal connections
comes from cpu SED Otto Graham who in
totality traditions stands for the
Gentiles sometimes would abide by the
divine Commandments and wished i began
to mean the friends of youth in a
overall nanshan society so to be outside
to choose at all so this some
etymological meaning was at the core of
the presence of the commemoration of the
righteous among the nations within the
multinationals project which has been
referred to as soon as I 1942 and this
opted for commemoration of the writers
one expected to benefit the Foreign
Relations of the future State of Israel
and but the passion was only right
you know in 1953 and one of his mission
was to commemorate this subscribe to
insult with the risks a larger sections
but this mission has not been fulfilled
drink 10 first years of generation and
it is only with the National Child
taking place as such and Michelle
actually remember I tuned for our
destinations and again the first
commemoration of the structures within
the actual trial was in a foreign
relation perspective it was first two to
treat the new German relation with
Israel tactfully and they're going
delivery at GD emotional works the
prosecutor to States during the trial to
refer to the Righteous among the Nations
as example or possible positive links
between these real estate and z foreign
States was via the United States and the
Western Europe States and for example it
is frustrating to see to what extent is
closing arguments the prosecutor for the
state paid particular attention not to
neglect any mention of any of the
countries where the slightest
self-storage Jews existed and then the
righteous among certain designations
were not referred to by that individual
names but choose a college
national diversity but by the beginning
so if the Russians nominations were
referred to during all of the HTM file
by thinning the trial the government and
a passion I got plans to create any
permanent Smith's of collaboration was
not only a punctual use of the evocation
of the righteous readings that action of
my contacts on this matter is a trial
stimulated a great deal of initiatives
coming from up outside of Japan and
Israel I can give example later she
won't but the main one was a watch which
Congress initiative the Commerce wished
to implement a well-conceived for a day
i want imran and this computer projects
like a pleasure to finally established
religions Righteous among the Nations
department in February 1962 first
request societies as the choice of the
Russians who were to be commemorated
will be naming strategy and state shows
without any formal procedure and that's
the recognition as a righteous will go
with the rotation of the tree which is
in israel national iphone and again in
all this process the perspective was a
diplomatic one the industry for foreign
affairs representative states in any
attention for the choice of the Russians
but as you may know the Oscar she loves
case which was meant to be included
within the twelve first trees were
supposed to be planted in 62 while
Ashley discussed by former European Jews
who lived in Germany during the war and
led to the creation of the formal
procedure no more only enemies tragic
and state stay one but with this
efficient
which it exists which are gentle talked
about and we won what my job I enjoy
and by survivors and resistance fighters
so between 1942 a 1963 in Israel the
title of righteous among the nations
took shape as an institutional category
but gradually and sporadically the title
of practice among the nation was meant
to qualify a minority group of
individuals and sister as a diplomatic
way to Paris a relation between Israel
and foreign country the gap is the
consumer contemporary meaning which is a
damn international text very striking
since in France today the reference to
the Righteous among the Nations are
meant to foster a read of the atom and
spirit and to help to see quite the
sense of duty no jewels and of all the
different groups within the French steps
this is a party of germany weasel
virginia
Tuesday's middle
so you know your actual distances shift
in the mini given to the commemoration I
would try to retrace the process through
which the very expression was translated
into French and by translated I mean
both literally and metaphorically who in
France titsbig first of these new heroes
and with which works and one so during
its first meeting in February 1963 and
in coherence with its criminal coach
inspiration recognition the Election
Commission enacting the rule that the
title would only be rewarded at the
request of at least to choose
content-aware a student and on the basis
of their testimonials in other words and
that was what interested me doing my PhD
work to become effective institutions in
Israeli institutional framework for the
commemoration of the writers of
information and instill us to be filled
by memories expressed by individuals
well until
emerging pages this framework I've been
barely feels as father Frenchman check
writers we're concerned so this is a
that I see there by 1985 almost 1600
polish and 22 2600 those people but only
three thousand 664 French people I've
been awarded the title of the writers
and intimations in more of our except
some very well local and a teammate
ceremonies in synagogues not only event
where in France ever dedicated to the
commemoration of the Rogers the
stratagem one never referred to it too
in the French press or the national
political sphere
the middle of instruments which new
writers were obnoxious were almost only
result in digit Israel in fashion and
photos in first was of them are still
waiting in the embassy
buildings as a bit of energy at nineteen
eighty in other words since by nineteen
eighty-five the commemoration of the
Righteous among the Nations was was weak
and limited to initial space it had done
had not yet been conveyed to friends The
Situation's changed in cages for example
with a shaman memory was beginning to
get to the depression as destination and
works or factory yesterday but also in
the decades around for mortgages of the
Jewish Christian network to ditch their
autobiographies and the associations of
the also analysis colleges on home of
was officially created
in addition its own dedicated to these
veterans open in 1982 and the form of
memory and analysis tells you no
falsehood from now collect 508 of
teacher of the veterans while ray
gathering of gathering wood one safe so
let's back to the debate we had with her
and it was not here talk before this
former Jewish Christians began asking
for an official recognition of their own
reason for bus Israeli and French
government's and in this process some of
them realized they had not paid tribute
to some of the non-jewish people who
assisted L inverse function in 1982 like
through there was a former partner on
the economic elites network at the
dynasty kelskiy first across a passion
as the witnesses and relies as one cycle
I'm sorry on high the casual way yet
measure has been dealing with France
recognition of the righteous information
and the
decided to mobilize themselves up to
change this first the one team or they
want to move more files to be open under
French lace for French names for 40 to
50 seconds as put aside the official
procedure and secondly they try to
develop the ceremonies in France I think
my local representatives pass the baton
ceremony in order to give them the
vehicle and there are their initiative
add some effects for example they also
we're the ones who wrote the case
generation bomb which some of you may
may attach to answer in order to have a
session for recognized visual base for
rescue and as you see
new franchise gratis each year after
their organizations the number new very
great challenge and awkwardly by asking
local representative to to practice
impacts in the commemoration the
step-by-step kind of fun creative
combination between the East Valley sex
symbols as the French state symbols
within the recognition of the Righteous
among the nation and the socialized part
of the French allies to the first volley
to volley lights to 60 stars
commemoration I could come back in more
details to this institution but since
why is it because of the actions that
projection back sort of the existence of
the stem in the nineteen ninety-five
speech Valley and spoke about before and
because in 1989 he was most of the
ceremony as my advice they asked him to
to close the ceremony so whether and
socialize socialized to the package to
potentiality symbolic to the choices of
commemoration of the ranches so I won't
come back to the 1995 my speech which
will already be referred to but from
this speech to 2007 a reciprocal
legitimation has been taking place
between the states and some of the
French Jewish associations began to
invest themselves in the commemorations
emerges because the fact kind of legit
too much to do so by the presence of the
sets and the press
state itself was more knowledge too much
to do so because of the application of
the sensor station finally in july two
thousand Aloha was balanced with with
which change the name of the July
sixteenth commemoration and called it in
honor of the victims of the resist an
anti-semite price of the french place
and in honor of the writers of France
but fact before this final test
originally the 20s who promoted Zulu
wanted to at the very very beginning
action if they wanted to give the
resistance classic types of functional
title for title to the Righteous among
the Nations and they did not manage to
do so because of negative reactions from
the states so after they wanted to
create a French righteous among the
nations title in front for me attention
that they couldn't do so because of the
negative reactions of the Jewish
associations so it resulted in zip sound
you
named for the commemoration date but I
can come back to the source of pleasure
and in a way for the ceremony was a way
to overcome subsample and to really
nationalize the sis commemoration of the
righteous and as writers and friends
I forgot to tell me
okay so this is a inscription you are
referred to and so you can read too much
cash and each one in it really gives a
new rhetoric of this balancing between
the fish collaboration and the
resistance of obsolete population but
what is very interesting as i see it
comes from a reaction title which is
only for very precise individual i mean
those who every participating to show me
more official recognition know how
difficult it was to have a village
procedure for it to a collective and a
collectivity of anonymous people to be
celebrating
late this is a queue of people with all
these things in the nsiah piece at more
than four 40,000 people visit is a
conscientious range as a conclusion I
just wanted to to to sort to address the
fact that this ceremony was a kind of
consensus in France even if the year
before in 2006 the French today a very
huge rush controversy the bells use the
passes mostly Rosalie the positive
columns and colonization no substitution
I took place in this case and what I
excited in my work is that the reason
why it's because we're not for most of
the Jews rescued in France a mistake to
Layton first this this investment of the
French stage within
original Israeli collaboration kind of
created a hybrid nine right
commemoration which could be simply
referred us to Israeli belongings as two
French ones and which in a way of feet
sometimes parties sometimes totally with
the actual Jewish identity in France and
as a completion i would say that from
Jerusalem to Paris from nineteen sixty
three to two thousand seven the
diffusion of the commemorative general
practice went with the diversification
of its symbolic interpretation while the
shift in the meaning of the state
commemoration implied in the way the
multiplication of the meaning given to
it by each engine
speakers in Zuccotti european jews of
funky university she is the author of
member books including Italians in the
Holocaust presentation rescued survival
the hollow house the French and the Jews
9 10 3 under his very windows the
Vatican mahal custom Italy and most
recently policies the Jews estate Martin
busy in their flight to France and Italy
meant 319 oh my
a number of wars or the books including
the National Jewish Book Award from
Holocaust Studies the national
commercial relations and the Civil
hablar Milton prize in the germ
segmentation should we talk at copia and
harbors and at Trinity College in
Hartford Connecticut and she's currently
complete biography a five min walk the
story she will be sharing the bestest
actually that should be that I've taught
a coma and are very clear love you and
it's very nice to be here I'm grateful
to those who have put together this
superb constant my remarks today will
really be a case of illustrating perhaps
and I didn't know it necessarily when I
prepared it but how it loves to give it
really is a many of the themes of this
conference I you will see as I proceed I
am really speaking about a Jewish
rescuer as well as a non-jewish rescuer
their stories will mesh as I go along
but I will begin with the non-jewish
rescuer whose name was here they told or
his religious name as a cappuccino
French capucine priest was paramount
even walk he was not nearly as father
Maya
debt though so if I slip from one name
to another you'll understand it's on the
same person better even though i was
born in a small village north of rj in
1895 panche as most of you undoubtedly
know was part of western France north of
the war the and also in south of Hobart
and in that question are in France which
was a very Catholic very conservative
and in fact remains so today that
marathon was ancestors in this little
village had been persecuted during the
french revolution by republicans because
his answers were wrong
counter-revolutionary very strongly
catholic activists so he had that memory
or heritage of persecution and then he
came up a local city came of age he was
about 10 when he became very conscious
of fresh Republican legislation in force
the separation of the churches from the
state he was affected by that separation
of legislation primarily because at the
age of about eleven he decided he wanted
to be the priest he could not attend the
local school in rj seminary for priests
because there was such a demand for
admission in the seminary and he was
still very young he wanted insisted that
he wanted to be a priest and he had
savitz two or three priests and as many
as eight guns in his father and mother's
family so it was an extremely religious
family he wanted to be a priest at the
age of 12 he therefore entered a path
machine secondary school but he was
unable to do that in France because
capucines after the laws of separation
members of the cappuccino order and
other religious orders in France were no
longer permitted to teach and very often
for washed out in fact
no longer permitted to exist at all so
they went into exile from France Pia not
yet the anomaly and while but the boy
who would become memory than one witness
the Exile of friars and priests of whom
he was very fun he witnessed the closing
of schools and when he chose to be a
priest he went to Holland to pursue his
secondary schooling in a cappuccino in
Hans from that school where he did
extremely well he was unquestionably a
brilliant young man and any brilliant
ogre men he went to he finished his
secretary studies and then went to I'm
sorry he did not go home on the first
went to Belgium and then for his
seminary studies to begin this study as
a
as a priest he went to Holland in 1913
he was he became in fact accomplishing
fryer but not yet Bourdain so we can now
call him prayer Marnie Benoit but in
1914 the war broke out at that point he
returned to France entered the French
army as an infantry private and fought
in the trenches for the entire duration
of the war even remained for a year
after the war for service in 1919 before
he was demobilized and his war record
letters of his war experiences exist
they're very vivid and he was after done
you can only imagine the kind of more
experience he had after war he returned
to Holland fellow to the seminary
studies when he was very quickly chosen
because of his excellence as a student
to go to Rome where he entered
international couple teen college and
also enrolled at the Gregorian
University in Rome to pursue both his
graduate studies in philosophy and
theology and he and to finish his
training as a couch in priest again he
did extremely well he was ordained in
1923 and as soon as he finished his
doctorate he was appointed to teach at
the college the corniche internacional
in Rome where he had just a few months
before I'm a student now from that
appointment as a professor of the
collision nacional de que pasa he spent
the next well the next intervening
period until the war broke out in 1939
as a professor teaching theology and
philosophy to capucine students at the
college and also many and if not most of
whom were already greased he enjoy very
much that the contemplative speculative
life the quiet life
but this was a man of two of two facets
really there was something in him that
also relish the active life as we will
see was he at any point in any of this
time interested in in Jews it's very
hard to find evidence but there is a
tantalizing reference that he made later
to the fact that he joined in 1926 an
organization called amici these right
head which was for the most part of
Italian organization there were some
3,000 priests bishops Cardinals
affiliated with the organization I'm not
sure whether there were none Italian
clerics in the organization of this
early day think so I'm not sure I do
know that the organization was banned by
pious the eleventh two years after its
formation in 1928 the purpose of the
organization had been to foster and
enhance and improve Catholic Jewish
relations and the organization founder
in 1928 when it appealed to pious the
eleventh and the Roman Curia for a
change in the
Liturgy of the Good Friday mass in which
there was the famous infamous reference
to the conversion of the perfidious Jews
organization petition for a change in
the literature in the liturgy and recent
scholarship and access to the archives
in Rome has revealed that this was a
quite a divisive present petition and
that the fact that pious the eleventh
refused the petition and dissolve the
organization is a little bit more
complex because we are now coming to
understand that there were a number of
products in Rome who were on the other
side who were in as early as 1928 quite
anxious to change this clergy it was a
divisive and fascinating issue but often
point he was there for for one reason or
another interested in jewish catholic
relations and a dryad miring of the
jewish people we don't really know why
whether it was because he met Jews in
the during the war during the first
world war in the trenches whether it was
because of his Hebrew studies at the
Gregorian
versity where he didn't really well in
Hebrew his friends in Israel later
reported that his keeper was really
bookish but not too bad whether he was
aware of some of the growing movement in
France in particular and in particular
among the Jesuits toward better Jewish
religious again this very complex issue
because certainly Catholics Catholic
priests and scholars were divided and
that's a whole other story but for
whatever reason he seems to have been
interested in in Jews and Jewish
relations by 1939 in 1939 he was in Rome
still teaching and he was sent back to
France and he it was actually mobilized
and serve as an interpreter for a few
short months in september-october of
1939 but when it looked as if the war
was going to kill me and that Italy was
not going to enter he was allowed to go
back to Rome from which he was ejected
quite rapidly in may of nineteen forty
one it became apparent
that way after all was going to come and
look more I was on the side of the
Germans he went at that point to
Marseille and at Marseilles almost
immediately so now we are in June of
1940 he began to become involved in
Jewish issues he seems first of all to
have he seems to be done by giving
lectures and throughout my saying to
Catholic groups about the need to have
compassion for those who were in need he
was particularly interested in refugees
and political go put those who were in
danger for a political political reasons
but he spoke of her I feel about the
need for compassion for Jewish refugees
were pouring into southern France of
course and into nurse aide he spoke
often at the convent of the sisters of
the doctor dan busy on a famous convent
and famous religious order which
ministers to use and in
many different ways for greater or less
great objectives of conversion but that
again is a long complicated topic he
been again speak publicly for the need
for compassion for the Jews he because
of that some Jews began to come to his
ice a convent sometimes because the
French single gentleman to his monastery
she was with knock on his door and say I
have a problem now most of those in need
in these early years were refugees who
had been in internment camps or had been
interned the long-term resident
immigrants in in France which were
Jewish or recent refugees from France
northern France from Belgium from
Holland who had a fro Germany who had
escaped just ahead of the Germans in may
of nineteen forty these were the people
who were in need refugees at Jewish and
none but most often for pepper even
while Jewish and then
needed fault that had escaped from the
camps where they were legal as but in
terms and they were now trying to live
evil ill illegally they were not trying
to escape deportation at this early
period 1949 t41 but they were trying to
live illegally and get out in France
impossible he helped them and it's hard
to pin down numbers it was not a large
group but he helped supply false papers
and he find hiding places he began to be
drawn in to his rescue operation and
when I asked him right and one boy he
said I I did it because I was a refugee
myself and I had no kind of world and so
I chose my own I want Joseph bass things
became much more intense in august of
1942 when the deportation when when when
vichy france began to expel foreign Jews
from southern France in extremely large
numbers at this point a man named Joseph
bass comes into the picture Joseph bass
was a Jewish Russian well he was a
Russian Jew born in Grodno educate
in st. Petersburg a brilliant man who
came to Paris and continued graduate
education to the extent that he became
both a lawyer and an engineer he in
Paris he had a very successful business
which she was forced to leave and flee
to the southern zone when the Germans
arrived but even in the 1920s and early
thirties he had committed himself to
helping refugees this helped to refugees
escalated when refugees and southern
France truly needed help and in august
of 1942 he threw himself heart and soul
into these dis assistance which was by
this time totally clandestine he has an
amusing quote toward where I don't have
time to read about how he recruited her
marathon wat essentially saying to him
you're making public speeches you're
talking you're you're here and you will
you put your actions where your mouth is
and peer learning them while agreed
completely in extremely close a
relationship ensued the two men became
fast friends some of their letters after
all during and after the war still exist
they admired each other I think her
family and wife like Joseph as
especially for this exuberance that he
had this kind of derring-do this extreme
individualism Joseph ass had a
philosophy of rescue which differed from
other Jewish rescuers which was that you
should not be allowed to stay together
they should not be put into children's
homes or welcoming centers much less
camps they should disperse with false
documents and and take on totally false
identities if they were going to survive
he was kind of an in-your-face non
organization man of course this kind of
rescue was more limited in possibilities
and numbers much more difficult to do
and many power Jewish rescue refugees
were terrified to go into the kind of
lonely isolation that was required but
Joseph as did it to a large extent he
recruited at first for his organization
called the centerpiece Andre he
recruited Jews and then slowly as the
need grew he recruited memory bandwidth
and other priests and Protestant pastors
in the area the final organization the
service on Bay was more effective
because of this cooperative
they each of the two men and their
assistants could throw on resources that
the other Clinton Joseph best new the
clients he knew who really needed help
and he also had access to mobys Lynette
and the Jewish Joint Distribution
Committee which provided a good deal of
the financing / Marvin wat into a
network already of priests who would be
helpful he was able to recommend
villages in southern France where he do
a priest who would take refugees place
refugees and he knew local parishioners
who would be sympathetic so together the
two men performed the great work of the
70s Andre with of course the help of
many others Joseph Basque was always the
leader of the survey's Andre memories
Anwar was just one of several assistants
and did not was not a leader at this
point but the skills he learned in
southern France which also fast he then
took with him to Rome where he truly was
the leader of an organization but again
working with a Jewish organization
called bell telus em with charismatic
dynamic Jewish characters who became his
great friends for life so he replicated
what he had learned and friends in Rome
and there at that point o is writing to
Joseph S is well not always but what he
could saying I'm continuing our work and
there he was able to say several notes
I'm sorry I have to cut so much but
thank you very much
I think to give you a few minutes to
gather your thoughts for your own
questions and start by asking myself and
I want to start out with risk
select an honor prices elimination FFM
you also mentioned is argued by others
that dress one of the reasons that
Jewish Vespers Andrews not been
recognized is that they were all after
all only helping fellow Jews were
obligated to do but I wanted to ask
whether in fact one could argue that the
Jewish rescue Arab Jews would there was
actually increased risk because that
world were doubly expose owed as Jews
and as people offering operating
against the law they also worth all the
living it more of like a different hairy
situations might have lost their job
they were operation under considerable
constraints and furthermore they
probably taste more severe punishments
if they were caught so we can one argue
that in fact being as you would rescue
were out intelligence but one of even
greater risk and why hasn't this been
taken into so i don't know if i would
like to answer that Susan and Sarah we
also have what I totally agree with you
you state employees and the claim that
jutsu obligated to risk themselves more
than they were a lady a twist of budding
June's and that's very superorganism I
think
I mean Joseph Auslan since that have
gone itself into hiding he didn't have
to risk himself he was arrested several
him a breastplate estoppel and then he
went to roshambo and then he even tried
to convince soldiers of ghia from the
tacos on the Germans endlessly to to
abandon even incentive leaves a month or
acid water it would be playful trial and
he went auto rescuer and also a common
app in Google shambhavi area he didn't
have to do this who's to decide who's to
say that an algae request for who wished
his life that person's a hero a Jew
invesco baristas likewise we can't quite
as much is simply had to do it go
through this job so uh such such a
fallacy but I think it has to do with
this mental block at the Israel the idea
that the only person
way of honoring our the fight of two
thumbs and forth and incidentally those
are the guns important as we say in
Ottawa talk about really it was a Nazi
department but none of them ever
derailed the Train taking Jews and death
camps try to derail it could have some
instances the only case that that
acknowledges and Belgium is once
transport that Jewish resistance stop
the train open the door apologies to run
that's the only case not important
neither cracked nowhere because the idea
was to fight pigeon coop German munition
chains and so forth so to people like
like what's up like Joseph last night I
want to mention because I yet was
mentioned yesterday Joe she ever went to
see some yesh and Sally and given a cut
long he gave of length of introduction
to various Catholic institutions bajaj
ahead could go with the letters of study
ash and they open it off through the
angels so how can you dismiss the action
of the first
and an admission at all I'm not saying
you should begin to the right is fine
right it's time mr. Gentile okay but I'm
sure we can devise another honorific
would use okay who actually went above
and beyond can I make another point that
yacht to shed the campout and save one
Jew is a righteous among the nations get
the middle to get the tree it serves
which is fair I was involved in that for
24 years i was involved in it ok but on
it so my contention is not to honor if
you say the moment you but people like
Walt assistance through us an accident
and he say little without the truth
through the help of ducks vs. all these
on pencils have treated the other i
will discuss key does not mesh so that's
I think it's a crime it don't have to be
corrected and hopefully will be
corrected I would just add very quickly
that we should remember that this is a
present
poland the intensity of the rehearsals
was not so great if you were caught as
if you are a rescuer and intercut if you
were an odd you yes of course some guy
but many were not many did not many were
imprisoned punished or reprieve is there
Bishop intervene if they weren't people
in the church their chances of survival
or at least could at least be fine as a
possibility whereas if you were Jewish
and people were arrested or in the car
you had no chance whatsoever just about
you were allergic when family is the
risk issues actually the core issue is
in a way as its incessant questions are
the same
jewish appears as an actor Dean
well because of the importance of
description between Jews and interview
as extension lines of course the story
of the country and in France it because
of the light stay and the fact that
since this distinction between shows and
notions you must not really been
addressed to the duty sir and if you
look at the veteran case I think it can
help us to think about discretion of the
recognition of jewelers we got here the
United 46 so silly the civil resistance
are received an official onstage
recognitions for Jews and non-jews and
amounted to act of civil resistance
we're the ones every news and you feel
you were entitled to special metal an
official recognition for you to whether
you were Jews or not and
this has to be wrecked with the ways of
subversion society and the 13 states
deals with this kind of distinction
between religious identity
there's a rest
we got one condition but you can stand
up and speak up a little bit server
computer great my name is name is Renee
weiner and she was arrested with the
anime a smooth long to geneseo nice who
worked at nice and fancy and
according to report I just love it but I
consider it important for if you were a
friend
Demelza said quietly you could go
through the war without being bothered
and at least inconvenience she risked
his life just by d I mean they're just
walking out of all you staying in was
doomed anyway so you know I was just a
question of about punishment we came to
be
doesn't that mean but I just want to say
to consider non-jewish rescuers
because it's all
and have you absolutely that's why I
just share we honored on whose respite
we do that but not at the price of
completely overlooking make people who
do pay to get above and beyond butter
beyond on going there is changing York
Lady Luck ameet may be available and she
in Poland she might replace place to
look for high defense the Jews but can
meet she winced herself some be 20 you
see what you said you were at risk to
find my counter argument is if you are
the risk if you are wasting you know
that people i have the you what do you
try to do you try to avoid being called
right you don't go and be double and
double the triple and make the risk more
obvious don't you try to save yourself
honey you try to save yourself and after
expose yourself even more and more and
more you are going you know people in
France like it's all money they traveled
on train
when the train back and forth it could
have been arrested dozens of times so if
you are wish then you try to take
measures to protect yourself and not to
redouble do it a little bit ridiculous
through to add to your risks more and
more and if you do that and you do that
for idealization for ideological and for
your monetary reasons don't you think
the people like that should be
acknowledged recognize what's your name
knowledge yes not invite you the Gentile
show look in a different way it's like I
think sarah has something to add a class
that case and the way attrition dealt
with it because for exactly part of you
also this could also have been
persecuted inherited a new project and
the creation decided to our beloved
example of work was born Jewish
gentleman in Ukraine and he was
converted by critics parents into the
Washington elects faith and then don't
divulge our evolution fled with his
brother to Germany and for Germany to
France and in France excited went to the
priesthood is any study for the
priesthood and then he had me baptized
again because the countries that have
affected in recognizes that facility and
he was saying you can increase and then
new the war he created his own network
is catholic network which the same
regions and he ceded to that are being
unfair after the war also helped many
many ways the growing Jewish state he
also helped to get use out of me luck
Iran in touch with you soon in church
the interesting thing about our beloved
who died ignitee next one for the left
of the war when he was at quickly put
his name of nominations of the righteous
Gentiles and his answer what you're
forcing me to be a Gentile I'm a Jew
don't you dare bring it up again and so
what happened he died and after he died
many of the people that had worked with
him Jewish people petitioned reaction
who have recognized and it was a big
debate at the Commission I I ask the
opinion of where my dog is their energy
problem and Robert L said if a person
assistance you can afford to get any of
this but Yahoo sham decided otherwise
does near the castle increase hey
reptile and then the Gentiles on this
one
yeah so many important points were made
this morning I hate to harp again on the
one that we've been discussing but on
this issue of Jewish rescuers isn't
another important factor to consider
that one reason it has been taken so
long to attach importance to do is
rescue that it raises the question of
what occurred in the Jewish world
particularly outside of nazi-occupied
Europe what occurred in Israel what
occurred in the United States and that
once you start raising those questions
you raised all sorts of cans of worms
that we have not been yet willing to let
in and one additional remark in that
regard is that we shouldn't you what
happened in Vichy France as removed from
what was happening in the rest of the
world that all this is interrelated and
just as a brush emma has thought find it
difficult to figure out what to do with
Jewish rescuers it is also the addition
Museum still does not recognize efforts
that occurred outside of the world
including in the United States to deal
with the massacres of Europe a total
refusal to integrate Peter Bergson who
led the most determined effort in
America to focus attention on this issue
what do you think yeah well
and everything even though on question
of the modules rest good there are many
available points I just wanted a I want
to mention indicator of Oskar Schindler
but before that one of the arguments
against that ottoman Jewish west which
is that place is what you do is oh
you're good old cuss know it's like a
minefield you'll be honoring him he
saves but he collaborate and so on and
therefore so go the position of the
admission since we don't want to step on
a mine field like Google custom so we
leave the whole program out but many
people don't know but I've done some
research and I found out that when the
name of Oscar Schindler came up in 1963
for information it almost caused that
the Commission to explode because there
were some people who claim that Oscar
Schindler and forced themselves on their
install their property and these people
petitioned that he not be allowed to
have a tree attention and when the case
came up for discussion and at the
Commission and they are combat
and it came to a vote and the president
the chairman of the Commission Moshe
Hondo he was a person who was who tried
out of action and he was a variant of
the commission of the righteous he said
that if the Commission votes to honor
efficient of the righteous he will
resign you not had a German who stole
Jewish property never denounced if I
spite of the fact that he says of the
talc use that man on the list and so the
Commission voted not to recognize
official in 1963 although hiago he
planted the tree because the cheese came
first it is complicated three and he was
anything he was only recognized
post-mortem after his wife Emily wasn't
Argentina when she was honored they
decided officially the aisle efficient
asanda I'm saying there are many issues
in honoring non-jews the question of
honorees
metropolitan ship this key in the world
and the question of onion ring goes
every year there are many points are
available points and one can debate
whether Jimmy a should be on the list of
the righteous or not yo gave us a head
chef position to be on he was hoping at
least and but that's not an excuse for
not doing anything I think he pointed
out we should also have in that moment
for Jewish West's Georgia have persons
like be a virgin otherwise knowledge
book and my fellow is Switzerland and
Shambo okay we should have some kind of
program lady without a medal I think I
need a metal because there they no
longer with us but we should have some
kind of program that they are included
within the fabric of Holocaust
institutions and not be swept aside
simply because there's a problem over
here because of truth in fighting or the
question whether they
acknowledge them ha that is something
for sorry Lou to debate and and fresh
out Sarah I I think it's so innovative
the way you're looking at public space
and trans the use of language
I would like to ask you to speak about
something that I'm read one of your
articles and that is about a
commemoration you simply that was
supposed to take place in a French city
for as used and at the local I believe
Communist Party opposed it does wonder
if you could just talk about that
example of the use of a public space in
your example is this Vicki garden
example to stage to the pilot each
ceremony can be interpreted in different
ways this case you are referring to
allow watch it
take place because some pro-palestinian
and groups leads to the local
commencement whether the initial
encounters 40 who are the involved in
this ass
the risk I did not 22 posts every girls
this age was a title and given by the
State of Israel so Sara Lee isn't a
place let's and it happens sometimes not
very often that she happened and Isaac
it into already a believer as a first
one of the first seven yet absolution
for the difference signals as I read
different masters were adding on some
very different speaking of very
different scene and interpreting the
ceremony very differently as it was the
pastor who took a cell a1 the local from
the jungle whether in a 1979 I think
when the first black was a potential
say okay we're very grateful to you
whatever you are to send us for what we
did for you but all you want to to
remember you of ways some that is in it
children are dying nowadays and what are
you doing about it to you what I don't
also it's not it's an odd thing we are
going to from time to time
question risk for as soon as you
mentioned earlier that not franais
believes different components and
elsewhere and there are certainly quite
a few rescuers in these countries who
perhaps didn't meet the strict
definition of risking their life yet
received presidential nominations
designation even perhaps very proud
did wonderful things what we're arguing
risked his life do we see a de facto
expansion in recent years of Riyadh
Michelle definition and the application
of this a bit of a devolution but an
expansion of acceptable behavior that
America wretches yes welcome when to
page inside the Commission's when the
Commission was headed by wash ave ste
motivation he was one of the Shinto
adarsh shinde Luton and later well he
came to judge it was on journalism
Supreme Court and he was the head of the
Commission for close to twenty year I
worked very closely with it and in it in
the committee whatever case came up and
someone said well in France especially
the members the Commission who were
polish halogen they said in pollen when
they call the pole was children the Jew
they took him out he shot him they
killed him they might have killed his
family and there were posters Wanda
population of death penalty for which is
and France people were not killed so
maybe we should not on a French twist
with the response of her basically was
that when we say whisk through it means
with any type of ways even imprisonment
and a waste where you don't know the
outcome there were cases in France like
bedrock were sent to concentration camp
Adalia talk to me anyway from others who
is sent to concentration camps and did
not return so the fact that they want
the potential that if you sheltered you
or help it you you may wind up you may
like other day or but she did not she
just protested the fact when she sold
the Jews in prison the truth and she was
sent to Auschwitz other lady so the very
fact that there was a potential risks
that meets the requirement and therefore
many French people who helped us way
added to the list of the writer so he
widened the explanation of the risks
after and she said one
respect that doesn't mean that a person
flow himself standing with the handle is
knotted around his neck it means that he
was disobeying the regulation to saw
assistance to juice it was get himself
into trouble in case of our protection
and no one knows where is this may end
and he was qualified and this has been
accepted that they are fish and
therefore many French people who help
Jews way added to the list so gorgeous
okay hair another question and then this
gentleman a great time so here at first
yes Susan here do your paper raises a
really interesting question about what
might have prepared more than wat to
become the person who came after
and that sort of suggests a larger
question about the extent to which we
know about non-human experiences in the
1930s or even before may have prepared
them there was four people pay attention
in class identity
thanks to think about it other than that
is emitted refugees and issues of
citizenship and Naturalization so did
you send more either about you or about
the larger question of the life of
rescuers before the rescue Susan can you
repeat a little bit louder the
microphones ever liveth in the back of
the year the question was of what i say
more about the preparation of memory
Benoit for the issues of you is going to
face in 1939 and 1940s numbers or even
better could I say something about the
preparation or the ambience hardy and
Badger upringing education off rescuers
in general now it's the question
only for friends that's one thing
nanotech of course in her wonderful book
when like here's the darkness did a very
systematic study of rescuers in Poland
in which she found that some of them
were and examples there was no common
denominator in terms of religion
religious observance in terms of class
profession no real common denominator of
in France the issue is probably
different but i don't know that i might
answer that early whether there was a
common and commonality i have searched
very hard for every vanuatu tried to
determine what influences there were
some of them but i really don't know why
you joined by me two days i am in 1926
you can study at least we're religious
for catholics and i think because in
front of a poem to it for that matter
but many were religious you can try to
decipher the religious message that they
were getting
from church in terms of use and the only
thing really that you can come up with
is that there were mixed messages and
people seemed to pick the message that
they wanted to hear so that there were
those who read secretary Romano and
chief Africa in France and in and in
Italy who would have read the most
devastatingly unpleasant anti-semitism
there are others who listened to what
Pope pious the eleventh might have said
and did say and took front of those
speeches which were often also printed
in a secretory the same the same journal
that was publishing articles about well
what's happening in Romania are hungry
in terms of separation from schools and
businesses they didn't say it was a good
thing but they would say said that they
were saying was a good thing so there
are mixed messages and how individual is
sorted out these messages is very hard
to know and then of course more type i'm
thinking more for those who are German
what how they read the messages we heard
last night in the movie about what a
John risa do who said pious the eleventh
said spiritually we are all semis well
that was in that was I gathered publish
in tanaja p.m. in 1941 so people do
about it but who heard who how do you
really hear the message and how do you
then sort that out from the fact that I
feel of it said nothing about the Jews
really / except for that one speech it
was really the only time you mentioned
at Jews and anti-semitism he did make
speeches condemning racism which were
brief and mail it's a very complex the
distinction between racism and
anti-semitism is very complex attitudes
of the church toward jews who were
observant jews different from attitudes
are the of the church toward those who
are being persecuted because of some
kind of concept of race who might have
been good Jewish Catholics but we're
still being persecuted for reasons of
race so these these
and that's only for rescuers who were
Catholic about common denominators I am
I still not happen so struggling with
that but I want to make the following
observation most of these people that we
honor and rescued there were in a
situation where they were challenged in
other words it was a physical contact
with an eye to eye contact they were
there on the scene then when I'm sitting
back someplace in Houston Texas a living
in the counter but what's that mean in
China they said I'm going to help these
people they happen to be on the spot in
many cases there was enough of the door
and a Jewish colleague came and said can
I say overnight and so on and there was
a direct eye contact or it was not an
eye to eye contact they were there on
the scene and they saw that each you
were being persecuted for no reason or
whether you have Co decrement about you
whether you
that's abuse or not but certainly these
people have a right to list these people
don't have a right to live maybe next
day I'm not going to have a right to
live for love where this will go and and
so you are they on the scene and
sometimes you see the victim bites and
in fun and what happens here then I
don't know who taught yet they were
bearing fried wherever I left New York
came to fight with a list of 200 names
and when he came to France many others
Felicity couldn't find him because they
were hiding we want to show himself but
then others came and hit sir officer at
his hotel room and something there were
hundreds and hundreds and there were
these people that needed to do to go out
and there was his proximity is
eye-to-eye contact so he decided to draw
the wall to the winds and to to use
every unorthodox method so the common
denominator should as a bathroom that
ditch incidence of aaron pryor 1935 when
you saw building but it's very hard to
understand what happens to a person when
there is that
that's very consuming either on contact
okay when you walk out of the street you
see a homeless person sitting there and
you passerby and you don't drop a
quarter of dollar what goes in your mind
is that president exactly nobody would
kill him so maybe tomorrow and I seen
I'll help it but dude the Nazi period
when its use funny and again for your
help and if you turn it down that may be
the end of it that may be at the end of
the line and so to say no what happened
at that moment when saying no could mean
that you are maybe doing that person and
you are asked to play God that's very
difficult there is no precedent of that
before and so it's very hard for me to
find a common denominator sure their way
exceptional people who because of their
background there were more ready to come
out and help but of the thousands of
righteous among the nations and yahoo
gentlest these are people from all walks
of life who never saw themselves as
altruistic in climb above the regular
person
and what we never think if you had asked
it would you be ready to risk your life
like a family like equality by Sheldon
with you they probably concept know if
it means I would lose my light weight on
that way but when suddenly there's a lot
of the goal of this person stands alone
and you know what's happening because
you're there you're there quality know
what's happening and to say no to any of
these people something happened which
they cannot explain later on they say I
was natural think they know why if I'm
very hard with a plate there in the
telogen expedition well none of the
righteous but they have why you helped
juice it's not because I read content
and I came to decision make sure you so
long if you could I have data some of
them said that didn't I
can I believe instead of its American
okay something just for an answer so
it's very difficult and I don't have but
the beautiful thing about this type of
help take that these people help without
knowing why that's the mystery that's
the beautiful thing about this after
unfortunately they were not too many but
I always ask myself that those people
that will be honest righteous the other
people who were challenged whereas and
the others who would not ask maybe they
have been challenged and ask maybe food
effects on war but they would ever
approach okay we are going for 20
one very very read us a story which was
so I heard the Hama tech who had studied
rescuers and was herself rescued in
Warsaw as a child with her family so she
lived through the worst of it and I
remembered her sent to a group at one
point so you know I was rescued I know
have children and she was sleeping the
horse it's working but she said I don't
know what I would have done if someone
had not
you're an astro it puts
ok work I'm sorry but we're just going
to more questions that I'm asking this
down with the waiting a long time and
then
I'm sorry this channel is believed a
very long time so I'm going to let that
ESP first I do have actually I
I do commend everyone to read he was
booked but does have a very good
perspective on what
who were able to it's not one of the
common themes that
concern was that many of these people
had an experience in their youth or in
the background that separated themselves
from the group I think that is the
essential thing that that happened here
people have been able to separate
through this room the people of Shambo
for example or mainly Protestants who
had been terribly discriminated
previously number of the people that had
illnesses in their childhood which gave
them you know put them outside the group
11 so I think that
okay clarify I've got a historical film
scholar
my friend Holly Mulcair people has
little cell phone and filmed the varda
installation so that i can see that's
how i started to work on what i wanted
to say was that what we need to
understand is that the commemorations
are in our content we have
look at the context in which discover
commemorations come and while it's
important to debate risk averse and what
people did at that time I think that the
tempering reception the effort to make
Jewish issues everybody's issues is the
important so this is what I wanted to
save our debaters it was not she pop it
in the whole notion of the state I gave
this paper at a pull up on top of that
and I'm excited she talk about her work
installation and she as which she had a
lot of that which is living together but
she either work with installation CD
jay-z that legal expertise in livonia
use so the idea when i travel to atlanta
pretation we're trying to catch our
games Reggie okay
jion said I go back to with other
children you know hooked up to the news
is about Klaus Barbie but it's really
about the children of ease you forget
that the dedication is desirable to of
their neighbors these are non recognized
people who did things like pull a child
from the stairs as the prepare to being
arrested and I think that we could just
the point is to start talking about how
we see things pairs on the father you
know what is awful you could talk about
that and thank you very much as a
obviously a very very lively discussion
in bed with raised many more questions
than we get out answer the low-pass but
when you take a break for lunch and
we'll start again humbly at one o'clock